huge crowds turned out and braved the
rain to catch a glimpse of the Pope it's
the first papal visit to Japan for
nearly four decades in Nagasaki the
pontiff leader wreath at a Ground Zero
memorial for the tens of thousands of
people including 8,000 Catholics who
perished in an atomic bombing in the
final days of World War two Francis told
the crowds that he believes a world
without nuclear weapons is both possible
and necessary and the money spent on
them could be put to better use in
today's world where millions of children
and families live in inhumane conditions
the money that is squandered and the
fortunes made through the manufacture
upgrading maintenance and sale of even
more destructive weapons are an affront
crying out to heaven the pontiff is also
visiting Hiroshima the site of the first
atomic bombing in 1945 on Monday Pope
Francis will meet survivors of the 2011
Fukushima nuclear disaster
he'll also meet japan's Prime Minister
Shinzo Abbey and Emperor na hito and he
will be hoping that they and other
global leaders heed his calls for a
nuclear-free world and to discuss it I'm
joined by a religious affairs
correspondent Martin GAC this is the
first papal visit in 38 years to Japan
what do you think the significance is
for the Christians of Japan well I think
that this important moment for the
Christians of Japan among other things
because in over the last sort of ten
years 20-30 years they have lost about
10 10% of the population it has actually
been reduced by 500 from 500,000 to
about 450 or so and quite clearly is a
pattern that the church is not only sort
of in Japan but around the world so I
think that one of the reasons why the
Pope is there is to try to regain
terrain obviously this also has a
regional projection
particularly probably in relation to
China were the Christian community
Catholic communities under quite a bit
of pressure as it has historically been
so I think that in the in the regional
context this visit is quite important
and just before the Pope got there the
Japanese Catholic Church criticized
Japanese society for being too
materialistic what do we make of that
well I mean the criticism was against
materialism and excessive consumption
and competition so I think that there is
a journal sense and this is something
that has been sort of following this
Vatican you know this de spoke for for
now since the beginning of the papacy
that the question of an unbridled
capitalism is something that is
essentially directly or diametrically
opposed to you know ideas of spiritual
growth and sort of the well-being of
people around sort of the more classical
institutions of church life and Japan in
some sense is sort of a linchpin
precisely of that kind of development or
if that kind of industrialization
consumption so I think that that was
sort of the criticism and you know it's
one that is consistent with the position
of the last few years okay thanks so
much for that
DW on religious affairs reporter Martin
GAC